Julia Pobst is at the church Congress in
Hamburg the hearing impaired blogger is
angry she wants to follow a debate with
German President URM gowk but she can't
see him from her seat ironically the
discussion is about rights for people
with disabilities the 31 year old
doesn't let up until a new row of seats
are set up for people with hearing
disabilities it's a small victory but
for Yulia Pobst this is just one step
sorry my comments guy who doesn't we're
gonna need my particular Jack the
Patriot army the blogger has an
assignment the online magazine of the da
Cunha charity wants her to examine the
accessibility for the disabled at major
events she sends her observations to
around 24,000 Twitter followers
sometimes every five minutes in her blog
nine Alvin schmaus or feast for the eyes
she examines issues that are especially
important to her the Internet has
drastically changed the lives of the
hearing impaired ya RAB very cold today
epica american dragon is olivia alice
cooper means do with that you forgot to
wear them a failure to recognize her
dedication and unpaid involvement won
her a nomination for the Bob's the
competition for online activism since
2004 Deutsche Welle has been honoring
international bloggers with the award
this year's prize went to chinese human
rights activist Li Chen ping Yulia
Pope's was the runner-up German
journalist falak Steiner convinced many
on the jury that she deserved
recognition in Germany things are
improving for the disabled but there's
still a long way to go in many countries
the disabled is shut out there severely
disadvantaged and at the bottom of what
we call society that's why it was
important for me to bring it to the
attention of the international jury
that's another julieopp matanza bling
blogging alone is no longer enough for
Yulia post for seven months she's been a
pirate party candidate for upcoming
elections to the German parliament where
she hopes to fight for equal rights for
the disabled she seemed for herself how
intolerant the world around her can be
after one TV interview she received a
lot of hate mail much of it from people
who made fun of her voice she took a
break reconsidered her candidacy but
decided to push on yeah i think the
doesn't physically stop in the frantic
but if the young manamana forgiven them
i hope but they are going to be done
some can open your clothes you have to
kind of perfect the ipad about european
throated jargon the election to
Parliament is set for September the 22nd
it will decide if Germany is ready for a
hearing-impaired parliamentarian
shift says a woman with a mission